رحلة شاقة عبر
الغابة كشفت في النهاية عن
قاعدة للمتمردين في معسكر ميانمار ،
فكتوريا مقرًا رئيسيًا في
انتفاضة وطنية
ضد المجلس العسكري للبلاد ، جاء
حوالي 200 متطوع من جميع أنحاء
البلاد بحثًا عن المهارات العسكرية
التي
يريدون محاربة نظام يرى السلطة  في
فبراير وبدد بوحشية آمال
الديمقراطية هنا ،
هم قرويون عمال شباب والعديد
من الطلاب السابقين
الذين احتجوا على الانقلاب ويعتقدون الآن
أنه يجب عليهم حمل السلاح ضده ،
إنه لأمر محزن للغاية قتل العديد
من الناس في بلدنا ، هذا ممكن.  يمكن
أن يمنحني القوة
لمحاربة الجنس العسكري
، المدربون هم أعضاء في الجبهة الوطنية للذقن ،
وهو
جيش انفصالي
طويل الأمد متحالف الآن مع كثيرين آخرين في
ظل
حكومة الوحدة الوطنية في ميانمار في المنفى ، هؤلاء
المجندون الخام
هم في اليوم الثالث من تدريبهم
سيحصلون فقط على 45 يومًا من
التدريب
الذي يتضمن دورات تدريب هجومية
وقبل كل شيء تدريب أسلحة  قبل
أن يتم إلقاؤهم مرة أخرى في
المعركة
التي يسلحون بها بالبنادق المحلية ،
يعرف قادة المتمردين أن المزيد من الدماء ستتدفق
هناك بالفعل أكثر من 15000 وما
زالوا يأتون
وما زالوا ينظمون ، أعني تعبئة
مقاتلي الذراع وهذا ما قاله
البعض
الطاقة تحاول تجهيز
السلاح لهم لذلك هي حقا حرب
أهلية أليست
تؤدي إلى حرب أهلية الآن هي من
نوع الغوريلا الحضرية ولكن أه في غضون
شهر ستتحول إلى
حرب أهلية تقليدية
قتال أخير  مع قوات المجلس العسكري
يعني أنه تم نقل التعزيزات
إلى خطوط دفاعية ولكن التدريبات السريعة
لها عواقب وخيمة على هذا
الشاب الذي أخبرني رفاقه أنه
تم تفجيره بواسطة عبوة
ناسفة كان يحاول زرعها
كجزء من المحيط الدفاعي
حوله.  هذا المخيم وحول بعض
القرى المهددة من قبل
الجيش الحكومي
، يتنقل اللاجئون بالفعل تاركين
هذه القرى الشاعرية
إلى معسكرات
التلال في  قديمًا لي أن النساء والأطفال
والشيوخ فروا من قريتهم عندما
سمعوا أصوات القتال
بقي العديد من الرجال في الخلف ولكن الجميع
يخشى الجيش على وحشيته
، وتقول جبهة تشين الوطنية إنها دربت
ثلاثة آلاف شخص في معسكر فيكتوريا ،
أولئك الذين تخرجوا
تم نشر
معظم أسلحتهم على الفور وهي عبارة عن بنادق صيد الطيور
محلية الصنع
ومخزنة بنيران مفتوحة
لإبعاد الرطوبة
، ويعتقدون أن هذه معركة عادلة
ولكنهم يفتقرون إلى الأسلحة ويتم تسريعهم من
خلال
التدريب وسيستغرق الأمر أكثر من
البر والبنادق
لإسقاط نظام عسكري
ومع استمرار الصراع ،
سيرتفع عدد القتلى إلى مستوى
قد يبدأ فيه الناس في نهاية المطاف في فقدان العد
سام كيلي معسكر فيكتوريا الغربية ميانمار